Korea I love Korean barbecue because
they just give you all the food you can
fit into your dumb fat mouth I know
about the viven Bob I know they like to
ferment things I dated a Korean girl
once
unbeaten jelly very appetizing name this
looks like jello animal fat
oh wow lightly jiggly this looks like an
eraser look oh my gosh
whew who would not like that the
consistency is pretty awful yeah it's
like if you made jello at a soy sauce I
got some mung beans second my teeth
please in Korea Elise did you take it to
leap off the tree and just put some hot
sauce on it is this like poison sumac or
some [ __ ] my palate isn't advanced
enough to identify what flavor this is I
just know I don't like it
No Oh weird he's almost like cleaning
products or tumbling what I like it leap
what are you doing is it bring back
memories of mowing my lawn you told me
you were gonna surprise me with a penis
it looks like a it looks like a treat
for a dog oh I bet this is like pigs
feet if I could guess I really like good
mmm
you had to use every part I think people
who have foot fetishes are like into
eating feet I like pickled pig's feet
and put that on my OkCupid profile these
it looks like a little crabs Oh little
crabs this is the claw the crap I'm
going for the eyeball I mean I guess if
you boil anything long enough they get
soft
yeah that's pretty hard
it's delicious
makes me think of like when you're a kid
in there like eat your vegetables
Claudia please that's a little like I
just say it's like eat your hot sauce
covered baby crabs
Claudia silkworm did you just say you
pay and expect me to not dry heave come
on mmm
I refuse to see if this I just can't
Sarah and Andrew refuse to eat this yeah
that means I'm gonna hate it
let me really open and like cool about
this yeah how was your day uh-huh Oh God
it's like a it's like a grass and hate
flavor gushers it's just like bite larva
juice oh no even if I were dying I would
have a hard time eating more than that
communes are harder dude they're not
afraid to you some [ __ ] that we are a
little nervous about have not acquired
those tastes yet that bug that larvae is
gross
I'm still kind of mad at you for feeding
it to me